[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
87 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing very well today.
How are you doing, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very happy, I'm back
from a couple days of holidays,
a very well-deserved holidays,
if you ask me.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
very excited about continuing
our episodes on the same
topic of, not support,
but the relationship between
customers and Google Cloud
Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we've got
a nice little theme going
of basically sort of what
our relationship ends up
being with our customers, and
how we interact with them,
in a really good way, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
today we have Jonathan Cham.
And he's a customer engineer.
So we will go over what is
a customer engineer, what
is the difference between
a software reliability
engineer, what is a customer
reliability engineer, what
is a solutions engineer.
There's a lot of them.
So we're going to be talking
about what is exactly
what a customer engineer does.
It's actually really cool.
And then we'll have the
question of the week for those
that love online content.
You're listening to
our podcast, so I'm
assuming that some of them
might like online content.
So if you're not able
to access meetup,
because there's no local
meetup in your town,
how can you access
to that content?
But before that,
we're going to go
with cool things of the week.
We have three of them.
And the first one,
I'm going to let
you go for it, because you're
the one that proposed it.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
we've recently
opened up a region in Sydney,
which is pretty exciting.
And one of our partners
there, a company by--
I'm going to assume
it's three weeks.
It's 3WKS.
One of the--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Could be three wakes.
MARK MANDEL: Could
be three wakes.
Could be three winks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, because
then you would add an N.
MARK MANDEL: But
maybe the N is silent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know.
Yeah, whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Anyway.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 3WKS,
whatever that means.
MARK MANDEL: The
author of the article
is someone named Andrew Walker.
He wrote an interesting
piece about basically
why they prefer Google over
some of our competitors,
around our automation,
and particularly
around the "serverless"
quote, unquote tag,
and why they felt that basically
people would save money
when using our server over
other cloud providers.
And it's got pretty
pictures, I think
is basically the big thing.
It has a lot of
pretty pictures in it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it has really, really,
really pretty pictures.
But also I like
that they actually
share how much they're saving
with their own project.
I do not know if
those amounts will
match to whatever savings
all the people might get,
but they're pretty impressive.
Like, they talk about how their
operating costs dropped by 80%
when they moved to Google,
which is pretty nice.
But if you're using things
like BigQuery, and App Engine,
and all of those things
that are completely managed,
that doesn't really
surprise me, actually.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
I think you had the next one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
next one is a new algorithm.
You've all used TCP,
that's for sure.
And the C in TCP
stands for congestion.
And there's an algorithm that
if you went through school
to learn these things, you
might remember how it works.
And it's really complicated.
And not only is it
very complicated,
but on the same time, it's
not incredibly performing.
There's a little
bit of a problem.
It has a long time
to actually get
to use the whole
bandwidth of a network,
because it starts by basically
uploading little by little.
And that's, among other things,
why, for instance, Chrome,
rather than having a
one TCP connection,
establishes six of them
to avoid these problems.
Now, the thing is that
that algorithm was not
the only possible solution.
And someone came up
with a new solution.
So there's a new congestion
algorithm for TCP.
It's called BBR, which stands
for Bottleneck Bandwidth
and Roundtrip Propagation Time.
And basically the only thing--
MARK MANDEL: Propogation
time is silent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, BBRPT.
The whole idea is
that it's still TCP.
It looks like TCP.
You use it like TCP.
But it will make it so it
uses better the bandwidth
that it is allowed to
use, which is really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I'm so glad you can explain
that, because I have no idea.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, basically I
like that in the article that
we'll link from the show notes,
they also talk a little bit
about the benefits for Google
Cloud Platform customers.
And they show a little
bit the difference
between the maximum
round trip time.
So the bigger the round
trip time, the slower it
takes for you to receive data.
Basically that's the ping time.
And in some cases, it went down.
I think for India it went
down by 50%, which is crazy.
So yeah, you will see that many
of your operations, network
operations, will be
much faster than before.
It is not necessarily
because we have
the best network in the world.
But also because we have
algorithms that help.
So it's definitely
worth checking out.
And if you're not curious
about it, just enjoy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you just
get the benefits really
without having to do anything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And finally, we want to talk
about a cool new product.
I think this is kind of cool.
Basically it is introducing
the transfer appliance
for Google Cloud Platform.
You may remember
back on episode 31
we talked about basically being
able to do offline media import
and export with some
of our third parties.
So if you need to, like,
put data on a hard drive
and send it to us,
quite often that's
the fastest way of
getting data to us.
As they put it in the
article, via sneakernet,
basically by truck and people.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
we had the two options.
One was sending hard disk.
The other one is
if it's something
that is pretty regular, you can
also set up your own connection
directly to a data center.
MARK MANDEL: But if you have,
say, your own data centers,
or even just your own
racks, and you're like, hmm,
I kind of need to move
like a pedabyte of data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: A pedabyte
is pretty big, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That's big.
It might be a couple of
hard drives, maybe 400
or 500, something like that.
We actually have
this appliance now
that you can put directly into
your rack, a custom appliance
that you can put directly in.
That will take about--
what is it?
A capacity of up to one
pedabyte compressed,
which makes it super,
super fast for you
to drop your data on it, because
it sits directly in your rack.
And then you can send it to us.
And then it will send it--
if you're going to send it over
the network, that might take,
oh, I don't know,
hundreds of days,
you can now sort of get it
in like a matter of weeks.
Which, with that
kind of size of data,
that can save you a lot of time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I wonder
how it actually connects.
I'm pretty sure that
it is pretty standard,
because it's just a box that you
can plug into your data center.
So I don't know if it's like
SCSI or whatever that is.
But it's a really,
really, really, really
incredibly big hard disk.
MARK MANDEL: Yup, but it's
also really cute looking.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is very cute.
Yeah, there's two options.
There the thinner one
with 100 terabytes,
and the slightly thicker
one with 480 terabytes.
480 terabytes is a
lot of terabytes.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a lot of terabytes.
It's more terabytes than I have.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
I'm thinking that my big hard
disk that I use for recording,
I think it's 4 terabytes.
So these would be
120 disks of those.
MARK MANDEL: I
only have somewhere
like 15 terabytes
at home, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wait, no.
Terabytes-- oh yeah, yeah.
No, it is a crazy
amount of data.
So yeah, a little bit
bigger than floppy disks.
MARK MANDEL: So that
sounds really good.
Why don't we then head
off over and have a chat
with Jonathan Cham to chat
all about customer engineers?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: I am
very excited to have
another member of the
Google Cloud Platform
family joining us today to talk
to us about customer engineers.
Jonathan Cham,
how are you doing?
JONATHAN CHAM: I
am doing very well.
And I am very happy to be here
talking to my favorite Google
celebrities, of course.
MARK MANDEL: Did you hear that?
We're celebrities.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you for coming,
Thanks for calling
us celebrities.
JONATHAN CHAM: I'll ask you
for your autographs later.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we can do that.
I can totally do that.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yes, all right.
MARK MANDEL: So
the funny thing is
is normally at the
beginning of every episode,
when people come on, we
ask them, so who are you
and what do you do?
But we're actually
here to talk about--
who are you and what do you do?
So who are you,
and what do you do?
JONATHAN CHAM: Oh, I do a lot.
But yeah, my name
is Jonathan Cham.
I'm a customer
engineer at Google.
I support many of the
Bay Area companies here.
And so if you are one
of them listening,
perhaps you have already met me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So what
is a customer engineer?
We've had many kinds of
engineers in the podcast.
We have software
reliability engineers.
We have software engineers.
We have--
MARK MANDEL:
Customer reliability.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Customer
reliability engineers.
We have many, many engineers.
What is a customer engineer?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
And I'm going to kind of
spin this back on you guys.
What do you think is
a customer engineer?
And there's no
right answer, right?
I mean, there's no wrong
answer, no right answer.
Everyone's got
their own opinion.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think it's
like a customer reliability
engineer, but he's not reliable.
MARK MANDEL: Does that mean that
that person comes late, just
all the time?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: You just
can't rely on them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You cannot
rely on them, I think, so yeah.
JONATHAN CHAM: So basically a
customer unreliable engineer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
JONATHAN CHAM: OK,
all right, all right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I might be wrong.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair.
JONATHAN CHAM: I hate to say
it, but that's totally wrong.
So yeah, I can tell you
a little bit about what
a customer engineer is.
But I have to first provide a
disclaimer, because, you know,
opinions are my own and not
the views of my employer.
This is a relatively
new role within Google,
and maybe within the last year.
And as we continue to grow
Google Cloud Platform,
we wanted to provide the
customer with a resource
that they can have access
to when it comes to building
their application on GCP.
So in short words,
our ultimate goal
is to help the customer be
successful on Google Cloud
Platform and own that end-to-end
technical relationship
with them.
We're a single stateful
interface to the customer.
And because we're that
stateful interface,
it allows us to provide
more strategic guidance
to help them make these
technical decisions regarding
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: So I'm guessing, in
theory then, if I'm a customer
and I'm thinking to
myself, I'm going
to build the next big thing,
whatever that happens to be.
And I'm thinking, how
do I store my data?
Or how do I scale this out?
Or how do I do authentication?
I can come to you with my
ideas, and you can be like,
this is good, or this is
bad, or something in between.
JONATHAN CHAM: That's perfect.
Yeah, that's exactly what it is.
Actually, would you
like an analogy?
I can give a good analogy.
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
JONATHAN CHAM: All right,
so it's good, not perfect,
but I consider us like doctors
and our customers are patients.
So let me ask you
real quick, what
do you look for in a doctor?
MARK MANDEL: Lying to me.
I like my doctors to lie to me.
JONATHAN CHAM: You want
them to be untrustworthy.
MARK MANDEL: I just want them
to tell me that everything's
going to be fine.
JONATHAN CHAM: OK, OK, yeah.
There's some of that.
We like to tell our patients
everything is going to be fine.
But when you look
for a doctor you
want someone who you can trust,
someone who's knowledgeable,
someone that knows
you very well, right?
So listen and ask
good questions.
And so imagine you come in
and you say, hey, Dr. Jonathan
Cham, I have MCS syndrome, which
stands for Massive Container
Syndrome.
Have you ever heard of that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean,
is that Kubernetes?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
what it is that?
I don't know what that is.
JONATHAN CHAM: Massive
Container Syndrome, it's
a syndrome where you have
just way too many containers.
So what are your symptoms?
Spending too much time
managing containers,
can't scale up and down
my app quickly enough,
my spreadsheet that lists
where my containers are running
is getting too complex.
These are symptoms of MCS,
and it's getting widespread.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
And so they come
to you with this.
And you're like, I have
the solution for you.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yes.
And, of course, I'll ask
a couple more questions
about their goal.
What other symptoms do you have?
And after listening,
we kind of do
some diagnosis and prescribing.
Maybe here's some medication.
It's called Kubernetes.
It's effective.
It's potent.
It will help you
with that syndrome.
The only side effect
is that you'll
have to manage all that
infrastructure yourself,
install, configure, update,
and build out the Kubernetes
cluster, very affordable,
accepts all health insurances.
Another medication, a drug
called Google Container Engine,
no side effects, higher
efficacy, but just as potent
as Kubernetes.
It will work much
faster, but the drug
costs just marginally
more than Kubernetes.
So you get the analogy.
The sense is-- we come in,
listen to their problems,
and try to provide
some diagnosis on what
they want to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, so
we interviewed someone
that was a strategic customer
engineer working specifically
for platinum customers.
And I'm curious about--
to become a platinum
customer, you actually
need to use the Cloud to a
point where if you overuse it,
we notice.
What about customer engineers?
Is this for everyone?
Is this for like,
can a new customer
just come directly and get one?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, so
a lot of new customers,
typically as we're
growing, we are
starting to assign customer
engineers to a lot of accounts.
And what that means is that
they might hear from us.
If they want to be proactive,
I know this sounds a little
sales-y, but you go to the
cloud.google.com website,
go to /sales, and you tell them
who you are and what you do,
there's a very, very good
chance that you already have
a customer engineer that
you don't know about.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So basically anyone who is
thinking about getting involved
with customer engineers or wants
to get started on the program,
they're able to do that now
and go there and get started.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
If you're part of a
legitimate organization that's
using Google Cloud--
if you're running your own
personal blog web site,
you're probably not going
to get a customer engineer.
I don't know.
Do you guys have a
customer engineer
for your gcppodcast.com?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No,
but maybe we should.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe we should.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
JONATHAN CHAM: Well, I'll
find out who that is.
But yeah, typically the
size of the organization
usually doesn't matter.
It's a matter of how
much are you using GCP.
MARK MANDEL: So that's actually
an interesting question.
You say this is for people
who are already using GCP.
What if somebody
isn't yet using GCP
but wants to sort of
have help onboarding.
Is that also in your role?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yes, that's
absolutely part of my role.
And that's actually part
of our typical engagement.
A lot of these initial meetings
will have customers who are not
GCP customers reach out
through that same website,
cloud.google.com/sales.
And they'll say, hey, I'm
using AWS, or I'm using Azure.
I'm interested in
looking at GCP.
And we'll go and
tell them about GCP,
but more importantly learn about
what they're interested in,
like, why do they
want to talk to us?
A lot of them want to talk
about multi-cloud strategies.
They want to talk about
having high availability
across vendors.
So not all clouds are
perfect, and a lot
of times customers who might be
happy with their current Cloud
vendor want to have a second
cloud vendor just as backup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that makes me think.
What does it look like
when, if I'm a customer
and I want to engage
with a customer engineer,
how would the doctor visit with
like following your metaphor?
MARK MANDEL: Do you wear a coat?
Do you wear a white coat?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
yeah, that would be cool.
JONATHAN CHAM:
Yeah, first of all,
I make sure I bring my lab
coat with me that has my name,
Dr. Jonathan Cham.
I alluded to some
of this earlier
about the doctor analogy.
A lot of customers
reach out to us.
And sometimes we'll
reach out to them.
But initial meetings for
people who don't know GCP--
we just discuss about
what their goals are.
I mentioned about
multi-cloud strategies.
But they also want
to hear from Google.
Google itself has a lot
of impact in the industry.
They want to hear about
trends within the market.
Just recently I was at a
health care executive briefing
where I spoke about the
need to collect information.
And there was a
Kaggle competition
about predicting patient
health care costs.
And they were super
excited about that.
So they were really
surprised about the maturity
of where machine
learning was these days.
So after an initial
meeting, usually there's
something like, oh,
OK, this sounds great.
GCP is cool.
Let's see how much I will gain,
or how much I'll save money.
What type of value add benefits
will I get from moving?
So a lot of times
they'll make us
do a cost analysis with
all the other vendors.
So we do that a lot.
And once they've committed
to using Google Cloud
after they've done kind of the
analysis, their paper analysis,
they go, OK, we've
decided Google Cloud
Platform is the way to go.
We like BigQuery.
It's awesome, totally
unique and differentiated.
We like data flow.
Tell me how to build my app.
So we'll sit in a room for
like three hours talking
about what they're doing
today, where they want to go,
how much storage
do they have today.
Just a lot of questions.
And a lot of iteration
goes on and on
throughout those meetings.
And in terms of kind of how do
you take that into production,
I mean, what do you guys think
is the percentage of effort
between taking it and building
an app in Dev versus building
an app in production?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean, do
you care if it actually runs?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Then, I mean, knowing
how hard things
normally are, I guess
it depends a lot on whether
you're running on App Engine,
or Container Engine, Compute
Engine, and stuff like that.
But I'd say that,
yeah, it's probably
50% more time I'm making sure
that everything is actually
monitored, the alerts are
set up, and stuff like that.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, a
lot of the times companies
have kind of like their
minimal viable product.
They do a little quick demo
running on a single instance,
and like, oh my gosh, this
is what we want to do.
But when it comes to
building out, putting that
into production for thousands,
or hundreds of thousands
of customers, they need to focus
on things like reliability,
availability, manageability,
performance, security,
scalability.
That list goes on and on and on.
So a lot of those
discussions kind of
reiterate back and
forth, making sure
that as they deploy this
into production that they're
successful in doing so.
MARK MANDEL: Do you
tend to also engage?
Like, I'm guessing.
Because there's multiple teams,
and we've had some on here,
like maybe CRE, that's
some big customers,
but like support teams, things
like that, you also engage
with them across the board?
JONATHAN CHAM: Oh,
absolutely, yeah.
There's a lot of different
people that are involved.
When I say all of this, it
makes it sound like I'm actually
doing all the work.
But a lot of what
we do is just make
sure we own that end-to-end
technical relationship.
So sometimes if the customer
has a specific, let's say,
Kubernetes error, we're
going to bring in support.
That's not something
that I would
be troubleshooting for them.
Sometimes for large
platinum customers,
like you had mentioned before,
they have a strategic customer
engineer who they've
actually paid for
to be their hands-on person that
will actually sometimes write
code, make sure
everything's up and running,
log all the feature requests.
Because these platinum
customers have a lot of features
that they want that
we might not have.
So just making sure that they're
happy, they do some of that
as well.
So for us, we're kind of
just owning that end-to-end.
From beginning all the way
to their next big project,
we want to be that
single point of contact.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So what is the
profile of a customer engineer?
Are you engineers?
Are you salesmen?
Are you both?
Are you actually doctors?
JONATHAN CHAM: Well, I think
it's a really good question.
I think they adjusted our
titles to be customer engineers,
because a lot of
us really aren't
coming from sales backgrounds.
A lot of these people that we're
hiring are literally engineers.
Some of them were
engineers at Google.
I sit next to a
Google Developer.
And he decided, hey, I want
to be more customer-facing.
So the people who we hire--
by the way, we are
hiring a ton of people.
So go to google.com, look
for customer engineer,
and see if you can apply.
But yeah, we're looking
for all types of people.
And you absolutely
do not need to have
kind of a sales background.
You just need to be able
to talk intelligently
in front of customers
and not be awkward.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That kind of sounds
not that different from
the role of developer
advocate, where we're
engineers, but we
need to talk, not in
front of customers
necessarily, but in
front of lots of people.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We don't
have the responsibility
of making sure production
systems stay up, though.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
definitely do not.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, yeah.
Like the doctor, we're
there for the good times
and the bad times.
When things break,
guess who they call?
They'll say, hey
Jonathan, are things down?
You need to help us.
Support's not responding,
things like that.
So it's my job to help, what
they call, herd the cats.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so that's
actually a really good point.
So it's not just
a, hey, I'm going
to help this person on board.
It's also the ongoing
relationship throughout time.
JONATHAN CHAM: Absolutely, yeah.
It's a very strategic
role, meaning
that you're with them throughout
many different initiatives, not
just one.
And I think that's kind
of where-- maybe where
DevRel or developer advocate
might differ from us is, yeah,
you guys are doing all this
awesome evangelism, helping
customers use the platform.
But in the end, you
don't have customers
you are accountable
for, whereas we are.
We actually have a
set of customers who
we are totally responsible for.
If they don't do well, we are
measured on how well they do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So from a completely
selfish point of view,
as a developer advocate,
one of the things that we do
is we talk to people and ask
for feedback on our products.
So I'm now wondering
what kind of feedback
do you get from customers?
What are the things that people
are like, oh, that's so cool?
Or maybe what are the
kind of things that people
are kind of surprised about?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, I
can talk a lot about that,
because, yes, I get all
the greatness and all the--
I don't know if this is a word--
badness from all our customers.
But the good things I hear
are, I think number one,
and this is just more from
a technical perspective,
but openness.
We have TensorFlow, Apache
Beam, Kubernetes, Bigtable,
which is HBase.
We have over 300,000
commits on GitHub.
These are things that no
other cloud vendor really has.
And it's not as strategic
for them as it is for Google.
Openness is really big.
And for large companies,
this is very important.
They've actually,
in the past, they've
had vendors that have locked
them in and they can't get out.
And so for us to really
be pushing this openness
around all these open
source projects where
we can tell them, look,
Google Cloud Platform
is the best place to run.
But, hey, if we're
not doing our job,
if we're not making
you happy, you
can always run any of
these on another cloud.
And that's a really
powerful statement.
Another good thing
that I hear is cost.
Usually we do come lower,
between 20% to 50% lower,
but it really depends.
And I always like
to say we're not
the Walmart of cloud vendors.
It's really, our cost
is lower because we
can scale at such high numbers.
We have like 1 to
2 billion users.
We already have a lot of
infrastructure in place.
So our economies of
scale are enormous.
People love our GUI.
I don't know.
I'd like to ask you.
Our GUI is pretty
awesome-- the Cloud Shell.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
JONATHAN CHAM: There's
nothing like it.
One button, boom,
you're in, ready to go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
probably one of the things
that I forget about
how cool they are.
And when I show it to
people that have never
used Google Cloud Platform,
when they're like,
oh, you want to
connect to an instance,
you just click on SSH.
That's it.
And people are like, oh.
I forget that that's not like
the normal thing for people.
JONATHAN CHAM:
Yeah, it's amazing.
And I don't know if
you know, but they're
coming out with a code
editor in there, too.
So really, they're going
to turn that interface
into your single
interface for everything.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, so I'm
just curious, I
think it's fair to have
the good with the bad.
What are people
finding frustrating?
JONATHAN CHAM: This is
sort of an oxymoron,
but customers will say we're
not as feature-rich, which
is a totally true statement.
It's factual.
There's a lot of features that
maybe a lot of cloud vendors
might have that we don't have.
We're not going to be able
to match feature for feature
with another cloud vendor that's
been in existence for much
longer than we have.
So, for example,
Postgres, right?
It's a very popular database.
We launched it in beta
in March of this year.
But it's a 20-year-old
technology.
People have been using
it for a very long time.
And we just announced
that in March.
And to be fair, we are launching
products like every day.
I don't know how you guys keep
up with the announcements,
but I get an announcement
every day about a new product.
MARK MANDEL: We have a podcast.
That's how we keep up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, yeah.
But I say that it's an oxymoron
because at the same time
we're releasing these kind
of traditional databases.
We're also coming out, at
the same time, Spanner,
global availability, global
consistency, like light years
ahead of what people
actually need.
But in hindsight, I
think it is Google's job
to really kind of meet
customers where they are.
Spanner's great, but
a lot of customers
aren't ready to
move to something
that light years ahead.
Former Hadoop
co-creator, he said
Google's living a few
years in the future
and sending us messages.
It's true.
We have all this technology.
We've had to scale like crazy.
So we built all
these new platforms
to allow us to do that.
But you think about
all the enterprises
that have been using on-prem
technologies for the last 20
years, they're not there yet.
So what we're doing
in the meantime is,
yep, we're investing in
all these great, awesome
technologies that we've
already built internally,
externalizing them.
But at the same time,
enabling our customers
to slowly move their
traditional workloads,
like leveraging Postgres
and things like that,
to our Google Cloud.
So I think that's kind of--
for where the features are,
we're still catching up.
I don't know.
What do you guys think?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
think that, in general, people
tend to have the view that
since Google Cloud tends
to be quite--
it's a pretty young platform
relatively, at least many
of our features are pretty new.
People tend to feel like,
oh, it's not as mature,
things like that.
But at the same time, what I
say to that is, well, yeah.
For instance, Spanner,
it's a pretty new feature.
It's a pretty new product.
But we've actually been
using it internally
to power Google for
quite a long time.
There's an experience
that is internal
that has helped
us getting there.
MARK MANDEL: And
that's definitely
a pattern I've seen
across numerous products.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, I think
the good news is, though,
if you're building a new app,
there's really no feature
that we're lacking.
Now, if you have
this old app that
uses a lot of these kind
of more older technologies,
there's probably
things that you'll
need that we might not have.
But I haven't talked to
a customer where there's
like this one feature
that's like, oh, OK,
this is a deal breaker.
We cannot use Google Cloud.
There's always a work around.
And I think that's
what makes us unique.
We always have things
that you can do,
that you can work around
any kind of technical block.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you
get to see more customers
that are coming to Google
with apps that already exist,
and they're migrating
them to the Cloud?
Or do you see more
people that are building
new infrastructure,
new applications,
and they're looking
for the Cloud
as the place to
build them directly?
JONATHAN CHAM: I think
there's a little bit of both.
So I actually have
dealt with pretty much
three types of customers.
Ones that are already
using a cloud vendor,
which is the most difficult. You
really have to convince them.
There's a lot of value
to move to Google Cloud.
It's not just cost, but there's
an operational cost to move.
All their employees are already
using another cloud vendor's
API.
So there's that migrating
from another cloud.
Number two is
moving from on-prem.
A lot of these large
enterprises are using on-prem.
They have their own physical
hardware, own data centers,
and trying to
figure out, OK, how
do we map that to what
Google Cloud Platform has.
That's part of our role.
And then the third
one, our customers
who are building new apps
already, they kind of just
said, hey, look, GCP looks cool.
We're going to start using GCP.
Oh, it's actually
working very well.
We're going to continue making
investments in Google Cloud.
So I think those are the kind
of three profiles of customers
that I personally see.
And there might be more.
MARK MANDEL: So now
I'm curious, what
are the reasons that you're
seeing people moving?
JONATHAN CHAM: Right
now I think there's
a lot of, unfortunately, a lot
of people want to save-- well,
not unfortunately, but people
want to save money, right?
And Google Cloud Platform has
a very, very aggressive cost
structure.
So in terms of like
storage and compute,
we are definitely cheaper.
And while I don't like
to emphasize like, just
come to us because
we're cheaper,
we do have a lot of value-add
products like BigQuery.
I think that's Dremel.
Dremel is the white paper?
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
JONATHAN CHAM: For BigQuery?
Yeah, you know, we've
had BigQuery internally
for many years, and
there's nothing like it.
I always tell a customer,
it's a three-step process.
Upload your data, write
your SQL query, run it.
That's very powerful.
There is no more setting
up infrastructure.
There's no more updating
and securing patching.
It's just getting real value
from your data instantaneously.
And so the trend that I'm
seeing across all customers,
and I think just across
the industry, in general,
is just people moving
to manage services.
This is something
that people realize
that the operational aspect
of managing the infrastructure
is not very valuable
to their business,
and they're trying to
get away from that.
MARK MANDEL: So we're
almost running out of time.
But is there anything
that we haven't mentioned,
or you want to
make sure you plug,
or you just want our
audience to know about?
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah, if you
want to reach out to us,
I run a weekly online meetup.
Just go to meetup.com/gcponline.
Actually, if you just
search GCP online meetup,
we do this weekly webinar
slash architecture slash
just banter back and forth,
almost like, obviously
not as cool as a
GCP podcast, but we
do some kind of a
webinar and demos
on a lot of these different
products that we talked about.
So join and subscribe
to us, and we're
happy to interact with you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I'll definitely check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Jonathan, thank you
so much for joining us.
This was a really
great conversation.
JONATHAN CHAM: Yeah,
thank you, Mark.
Thank you, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: A huge thanks to
Jonathan for joining us today.
It is really nice to
hear what happens,
not necessarily
behind the scenes,
but behind customer
engagements that happen with us
and some of our customers.
That's really, really
nice, and how we
like to basically
take care of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I'm looking forward
to seeing his updated business
card with the new title,
customer unreliable engineer.
We will see if he
actually does that.
But before we finish,
and before I get fired,
let's talk about the question
of the week, which is actually
very related to what
Jonathan Cham does.
So the question was,
basically, OK, I
am in some random
place in the world.
And unfortunately I am not
able to access local meetups.
And if you're in San
Francisco, there's
a bunch of local meetups.
And it's really cool.
But if you're somewhere else
where you cannot access those,
what do you do?
Some of those meetups
actually record their talks
and publish them.
But it's even better if those
meet ups happen directly
online.
And I think that Jonathan
Cham does exactly that.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, so he runs,
or I think he helps run,
anyway, he's directly involved.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: He somehow
hosts the thing, which
is weird because it's online.
So I'm not sure what that
means to host it, but yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It is the Google
Cloud Platform online meetup.
So there have been a series--
I'm actually just
going through the now.
There's a lot of
really cool meetups
that have been going
on for quite a while.
I want to say once
a month or so,
where they do live YouTube
streaming of presentations
where you can interact
directly with the presenter
and hang out with a
bunch of other people
who are also online
watching the same thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I really like them.
There's one of them
that I definitely
want to watch, getting started
quickly with machine learning
on Google Cloud Platform.
One of the reasons
why I want to watch it
is because I can
see that there's
a little picture of
Bender from Futurama.
Definitely check it out.
The coolest part of this is
that it happens online directly.
So it's not only you
can watch the video
and ask questions
in the comments,
you can actually ask questions
to the speaker on real time,
which is very, very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and if you happen
to have managed to miss
it for whatever reason,
they're available
as well on YouTube,
And we'll put a link
in the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep, we will.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, well, Francesc,
before we wrap up today,
are you up to anything
interesting and exciting
lately?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, I do not
do anything interesting anymore.
I just publish the episodes for
Just for Func every two weeks.
And on Monday, I
released one on how
to do unit testing
of web servers
in Go, which is something
that not that many people do.
So if you're interested
in it, go check it out,
justforfunc.com.
And other than that, holidays.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm going
to hang out a little bit.
My next event will be PAX
Dev and then PAX West.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which is?
MARK MANDEL: Late August,
early September, so
that's in Seattle.
If you play games, and
know games, and love games,
then you probably are familiar
with these conferences.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, Mark, thanks so much
for taking the time today to,
again, record an amazing
episode of Google Cloud Platform
podcast.
MARK MANDEL: And thank you
so much for joining me.
And thank you very much to
everyone for listening as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
[MUSIC PLAYING]